en chine un mystérieux virus de la même
famille que le strass a déjà contaminé
quarante cinq personnes un chiffre
beaucoup plus important selon des
scientifiques
une épidémie qui inquiète d'autant plus
que le nouvel an chinois approche le
virus pourrait se propager à l'étranger
les premières victimes auraient été
contaminés sur ce marché aux poissons
fermé depuis en cours de désinfection
ici on soit une soixante de patients
infectés par le virus deux personnes
sont mortes les malades présentent des
symptômes de pneumonie malgré des
mesures drastiques
les autorités chinoises se veulent
rassurantes la chine vient de confirmer
que ce virus respiratoires aux symptômes
comparables à la grippe et est
transmissible d'homme à ici comme dans
tout le pays la grande transhumance du
nouvel an chinois a déjà commencé les
autorités craignent que ce chassé croisé
de 450 millions de chinois accélère la
propagation du virus une troisième
personne vient de mourir à l'hôpital de
roura nous près de 200 patients
souffrent de troubles respiratoires
ils achètent aujourd'hui pour la
première fois deux nouveaux cas sont
annoncées dans d'autres grandes villes
comme pékin shenzhen ou encore au rwanda
depuis la ville de roanne des passagers
infectées ont propagé le virus dans
d'autres pays d'asie la thaïlande le
japon et dernier en date la corée du sud
en france dans les aéroports des
affiches ont fait leur apparition pour
les personnes qui rentrent de chine en
cas de fièvre ou de tous il est
recommandé de porter un masque et de
contacter immédiatement le samu
le ministère de la centaine n'annonce
pas à ce stade de restriction pour les
voyageurs
c'est du jamais vu des millions
d'habitants placés en quarantaine les
autorités chinoises ont bouclé ce matin
trois villes dont murano foyer de
l'épidémie de pneumonie qui a fait 18
morts et plus de 634 malades en chine
l'ordre a été donné ce matin plus de
trains plus d'avions les routes pour
sortir de la ville 2 orane sont
désormais bloqués pour anne est une
ville sous cloche il est midi nous
sommes coupés du monde d'ailleurs en
ville plus de métro de restaurants les
centres commerciaux ont tiré le rideau
il est 14 heures une réponse adaptée en
attendant beaucoup de gens se demande
ici combien de temps cette quarantaine
peut durer et si elle suffire à endiguer
l'épidémie ce virus qui a fait 18 morts
et contaminé près de 600 personnes et
ils virulent
difficile à dire pour l'instant on sait
qu'il provoque de la fièvre et des
difficultés respiratoires
les autorités sanitaires s'efforcent de
mesurer sa vitesse de propagation nous
ne savons pas à quel point ce virus est
contagieux
donc tout ce que nous savons c'est la
durée d'incubation entre deux et douze
jours mais nous ne savons pas lorsqu'une
personne est contaminée combien
contamine de personnes nous avons besoin
de plus de données venant de chine pour
pouvoir modéliser le risque et puis je
vous confirme que la ministre de la
santé agnès buzyn vient à l'instant
d'annoncer qu'un cas de corona virus est
détecté sur le territoire français au
chu de bordeaux on y reviendra
[Musique]